the cw's team drama riverdale brings a
world of classic archie comics to a
contemporary setting
and the premise has resonated with
audiences for four seasons so far
with season five on the way the show's
success has much to do with its charming
willingness to fully embrace the
weirdest most ridiculous plots the
writers can conjure
like storylines about the terrifying
gargoyle king or a serial killer known
as the black hood
while riverdale is more than happy to
take the plunge into the strange and
surreal
it's always been anchored by the
flexibility and chemistry of its capable
stars
still even the actors sometimes feel
that certain scenes are a bit much
in a recent interview of the los angeles
times betty actress lily reinhardt
discussed one particular betty scene
that almost went too far
outside her comfort zone according to
the actress she struggled with one
particular riverdale season 4 scene that
required her to show more skin
than she was comfortable with
particularly since society
and the entertainment industry alike
have long pressured women to look a
certain way and she felt she didn't fit
that standard
reinhardt told the los angeles times i
don't have the cw girl body
tiny ways to nice shaped legs skinny
small
tiny i had to do a brown underwear scene
in this last season
season 4 and i felt really insecure
about it i really
really didn't want to do it she then
went on to say that while no one forced
her to perform the scene
the experience of filming it wasn't
exactly pleasant i wasn't pressured into
doing it
i did it because it was my job but i
felt bad about myself doing it
i really did reinhardt is fully aware
that her decision to shoot the scene
despite her considerable discomfort
might strike someone as odd however
she's a proponent of body positivity and
as such
she's quick to point out that she felt
the need to shoot the scene
to show the world that not everyone
needs to look like a finely sculpted
fashion model
i can't preach body positivity if i
don't practice it so
even if i'm not feeling amazing about my
body i felt it was important for me to
do the scene anyway in my brown
underwear so people could see my body as
it was
i did it for the people who feel like
they need to look a certain way in
general the actress isn't a fan of the
way our culture and social media
promotes a certain type of perfect body
she went on to say
you go on instagram and i'm like oh look
all these people with these beautifully
toned bodies
and then go to the beach does anyone on
the beach in the real world look like
that
i don't see anyone looking like this
instagram and victoria's secret runways
are not a portrayal of how people look
in real life
historically reinhardt hasn't been
afraid of taking the ball by his horns
when it comes to discussing her
struggles with body image
she's said that she considers her own
body to be quote average
especially compared to her riverdale
co-stars in the past reinhardt has also
criticized the body image pressures of
the industry
noting that she has witnessed several
actors going without food for 12 hours
in order to appear in certain scenes in
february 2020
reinhardt opened up about her
insecurities in more detail on twitter
responding to another useless now
deleted tweets that presumably was
criticizing her appearance and or the
appearance of a riverdale co-stars she
wrote
actually not everyone on this show is
perfectly chiseled and even i feel
intimidated by the physique of my
surrounding castmates sometimes when i
have to do bra underwear scenes
reinhardt also revealed that she
struggles with things like cellulite and
weight gain
and her history of depression doesn't
exactly help matters however she's
perfectly aware that the problem
ultimately lies with the skewed beauty
standards of the entertainment industry
rather than her this industry struggles
with accurate representation of female
and male bodies
so i commend the women who have helped
our industry take a step in the right
and authentic direction we are all
imperfectly
beautiful so let's embrace that and
practice that
in a healthy way check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one